joined now by the former victims
commissioner Dame Viera bird hi Dame
Vera thanks for joining us on the
program your thoughts on this case first
of all
this was a the whole judgment has been
released last night this is a woman of
44 with no previous convictions three
children during lockdown had gone back
to her a strange partner though she was
involved with another man whose
pregnancy it was it's clearly not a
design desired pregnancy maybe a failure
of contraception she can't get a scan
she doesn't know exactly but there's no
doubt she knows roughly how long she's
gone and she doesn't know what to do she
doesn't see a doctor because she's
embarrassed and all the evidence is
she's rushing around in an emotional
turmoil exercising her conscience in a
proper way it seems to decide what she
can and what she can't do and in the end
she must decide that she needs to that
is the con what happened that she needs
to have an abortion so then of course
she's in a position where she has to lie
to get the pills and she takes them it's
I don't understand for one minute the
appalling consequences to her
because you know taking pills to have an
abortion is relatively uh light thing
but this is wholly different late in the
day Emergency Services called and so let
alone you know the the fetus and the
position of that are being very well
developed this is overwhelmingly a woman
who needed the help and support of
medical and other services and couldn't
get them and didn't get them and to send
the person of this kind to prison seems
to me to be not in a public interest in
any way if she lived 100 miles further
to the West in Northern Ireland where
this government that we have took power
and abolished the criminality of
abortion in 2019 then she would not be
where she is now so this I think is has
not done anybody any good as an
individual she needs to appeal this
sentence and there is a danger as very
well expressed by the senior medical
people who wrote to the judge the Royal
College of Obstetricians Etc about 10
senior health figures there is a bit of
a danger that Prosecuting somebody in
this way puts other people off
exercising their uh their decision uh in
in a proper way they won't know exactly
what time limit it is and so on people
are not all universally especially in
this state
socially accomplished and able to sort
things out they need help and support so
my view is that the sooner we abolish
this criminality which comes from an
1861 statute long before women had a
vote or any say in it and has been
scrapped in Northern Ireland to no known
ill effect the better and we do need in
my view and access right to abortion
services for all women in this position
so that they can get all the advice and
medical help they need you know either
way in either direction whatever they
choose but human right of access to that
so no one ever has to shake in their
shoes at the prospect of going to a
doctor and saying you know I'm not
married or I'm having Affair and I'm
pregnant those two things hey Dave let
me ask you this the judge said that if
she'd pleaded guilty earlier he may have
been able to consider suspending her
jail term
um what are your thoughts on that
I think that's something the court of
appeal is going to have to sort out
because uh she couldn't plead guilty to
this at the magistrates Court he does
say very clearly that he felt he would
have been able to suspend the sentence
and given that the you know the judge is
stuck with this ancient law and a
prosecution that frankly is not in the
public interest in my view ever to have
been brought he stuck with that but the
suspended sentence brought in my view of
being the best sentence she was not
charged with this offense at the
magistrates Court it was after that that
her Barrister wrote to the CPS and
suggested this offense instead of child
destruction so there's a model up there
the prosecution agreed put the charge in
she pleaded to it about three months
before the trial she should you know I
mean this woman has you know because of
her emotional state and the lack of help
missed one time table in the abortion
field she is now imprisoned because
she's missed another timetable which
probably was absolutely not her fault so
I hope the court of appeal uh I hope she
appeals she really must and I let the
court of appeal takes care of it but
never letting anyone get into this
situation again can be brought about by
regularizing the law just as it has been
done in Northern Ireland and that seems
urgent to me and assuring people that
they're entitled to abortion advice if
they find themselves in this position so
they have no hesitation but to seek help
okay thank you very much indeed for
joining us on the program